oh hi welcome to analyze this this is
Matt Barrett scholastic coordinator at
the Chess Club and I'm subbing for Yasir
today I'd like to go over a few games I
think there's at least one game in the
audience and then a couple of my own I'm
gonna start with a game I played at the
National Open in 2012 this was against
Joshua Shang he's actually he's actually
pretty good now but at this time he was
2100 so at this time I actually had a
repertoire and my first move was be four
and I had already planned if I meant the
Sicilian that I would play one of the
Bishop b5 lines and so Knight f3 d6 I
really didn't have to make any decision
here this was the move that I had set
there are actually three choices he
could make here knight c6 Knight BD 7 or
Bishop d7 he chose the most challenging
of the three Bishop d7 that puts this
question immediately to my bishop shall
I defend it or shall I exchange I chose
the most popular option to exchange and
he chose the most popular to take back
with Queen this is a good way for black
to fight for equality right off the bat
so I castled although there were some
there were some other choices here I had
to ask myself whether I wanted to open
the game immediately with a move like d4
did I want to play something a little
bit more passive pawn to d3 supporting
efore and going for a kind of a
long-term positional play I really was
looking especially against a higher
rated player for some activity and as a
result I chose this castling move had I
chosen d4 I had looked at the line see
takes
Queen takes Knight c6 Queen d3 those
moves are actually played in some other
top games and actually in this time I
really was in good tournament shape so I
remember having prepped for this and
this was an option it just wasn't
something I was fully comfortable with I
was looking at the games of a vladimir
klein ukrainian grandmaster and this was
not how he liked to play it so
alternatively what other what other
considerations were there do i want to
break up the center with a move like 'if
i've where after take take in Queen e6 I
can play Queen e2 and if 96 and I takes
Queen takes this looks like a kind of a
boring game so with that in mind I I
didn't want to trade things too quickly
and and I did go for that castle okay
now black may play g6 he may play Knight
f6 he may play knight c6 he played
Knight f6 which is not actually the most
popular most $5 nice c6 so I responded
with Knight c3 I could have played rook
e1 and still I'm holding back on that d4
move because I want to be sure that's
what I'm gonna play as opposed to d3
knight c6 okay had the knight not come
out I think I may have played d3 but
with a night out like that I think my
decision was made up for me there's no
LightSquared bishop so d4 takes takes c6
if he takes with night that's actually
going to be a little bit better for me
there's nobody to evict my Queen from
the d4 square so one possibility we've
been Knight takes Knight Queen takes and
I would have felt like I was in the
driver's seat there so II six and I can
choose between III
Bishop e3 f 3 or maybe Bishop to g5 and
I had looked at Bishop g5 with a
computer and it seemed like that wasn't
wasn't really leading to any kind of
advantage for white not that not that I
necessarily was looking for an advantage
sometimes I like to trade pieces and go
to go to an endgame
so here with the idea of keeping my
queen on the board probably was thinking
in terms of Bishop III and that's that's
that's how I I decided on that move
Bishop e7 and now trying to figure out
am I going to pressure d6 which side of
the board is he gonna castle on clearly
the King side if he castles Queen side
I've got a lot of pressure my bishop at
e3 two knights ready to go into b5 so
one question is whether I want to trade
nights or whether I want to put the d4
Knight at b5 is that going to do
anything let's see a six and and I'm not
getting anywhere so can i play Queen d2
followed by rook at eight at d1
something of that nature these are
things I'm I'm asking myself but I
realized that I want to play the move f4
what I didn't realize was that I should
have played it immediately and so I
thought maybe it would be a good idea to
put my King in a slightly safer place
before I did it
I think this turns out to have been a
poor choice but but that's what I what I
started thinking so first rather than
Queen d2 I play Queen e2 he castles and
I play rook at a to d1 so I'm still kind
of thinking you know I'm gonna play King
h1 I'm gonna play f4 but before I did it
I wanted to make sure that wasn't my
queen who was going to be subject to
pressure down the D file when he plays
his eventual d5 he plays a6 kind of slow
and this is where I should have played
f4 rook a d8 this is definitely better
for me
one possible move would have been g4
right I'm really throwing caution to the
wind this isn't the way I necessarily
wanted to play but this is what Houdini
later recommended
instead I played king h1 and he plays b5
so he's got some counter play on the
queenside
how soon am I gonna have to defend over
there not quite clear i play a three and
I think that wasn't my best choice
he plays Queen b7 it kind of a strange
move I'm looking for some clarity in the
center of the board I know d5 is coming
I'd like to play e5 but of course I
can't do it right now
his queen at b7 okay one possible
explanation is that it's kind of eyeing
my King on that diagonal so no longer do
I have options like g4 down the line so
those are things I should be thinking
about is it too late for me to play f4
for example well I decided that it was
that I'd rather put both rooks in the
center and try to open things either on
the e-file or the D file depending on
where his rooks go
no I didn't okay
at first I played f4 which I think I
must have realized at this point that I
was going to play that I wasn't going to
be able to play g4 so after rook at a to
c8 I retreated Knight to b3 two things
in mind one he's probably going to be
playing before before long I'm starting
to look at the bishop on e7 I wonder if
I can play one of these thematic Knight
d5 moves and so I so this is where let's
see rook at a rook at F to d8 I retreat
my Bishop eyeing that Bishop at E 7 so
my queen is now starting to do a little
bit more Bishop pawn to a5 and rook at F
2 e1 so I'm kind of trying to play a
kind of a confused game because on the
one hand I want to attack but my
calculating ability is probably not good
enough
for me to see how far ahead I can do
this
can i play Knight d5 immediately is one
question that I ask myself if he plays
b4 can i play Knight d5 pawn takes
Knight takes rook takes Knight at d5 if
he plays b4 and I play pawn takes and he
plays pawn takes
can i play Knight d5 so this is what I'm
looking at and it's actually confirmed
later by the computer I can play this
but I probably should have played
something more reasonable here
Knight a4 would have been a possibility
pawn takes pawn was a possibility but I
played 95 I was going for it I was
playing a high rated player and I
thought this would be a good way to mix
things up of course he doesn't he
doesn't want to take it so two options
here include a 4 and B taste a 3 I think
he he should have played B takes a 3 he
actually played a 4 and now Knight takes
Bishop Queen takes and Knight d4 now the
reason I'm bringing the knight to d4 is
to trade some pieces off and concentrate
on his Queen side he's got a pawn at a
for a pawn at b4 and I think I can take
both of those off and be left with
either a C pawn or an a pawn when he
captures and I capture he captures and I
capture he probably misjudged this
situation he's looking from his
perspective and at the possibility of
capitalizing on this week pawn at a 3 so
he sees that his Queen at e7 is eyeing
that threw the pawn at d6 I think this
helps explain why he plays the move d5
Houdini had recommended Queen c7 which
shows a little bit more restraint
pressures might see two pawn and
possibly brings into play ideas of a
piece on c3
for example let's see for example after
Queen c7 rook takes a for queen takes
rook takes now I have a passed pawn I
thought this would be better for me I
really did but the computer says that
this is really pretty equal
so five pawns against five pawns I have
a bishop actually Julian this reminds me
if our game in a sense right because I I
would have thought that a passed a pawn
was a good thing and turns out it
sometimes it can be blockaded so instead
another option would have been a five
where F takes D takes and now rook takes
a four can be answered with this
interesting move rook c3 he he's
attacking two pawns at once but most of
his attentions going to the a three
point once that pawn comes off the board
the C pawn is much less dangerous
because the black King's a lot closer to
it so with that in mind I was pretty
happy that he played d5 this move can't
be right
after captures Knight captures I have
this move f-fine
so this is where the game got exciting
Josh doesn't have much time he's looking
at my weak a3 pawn and asking himself
whether he can capture it without
suffering any ramifications notice that
if Queen takes a three F takes c6
he can't take back with his F pawn and
if he retreats his Queen to e7 I still
have some interesting ideas there
his Knight d5 would now be under
additional pressure the e6 pawn is is
what's defending it meanwhile his a pawn
is gonna be pretty easy for me to pick
up if I need to so not necessarily
thinking in concrete lines just looking
at the threats F takes G 6 looks like
something he should be thinking about
and fortunately for me he plays Queen
takes a 3 and without any hesitation I
played F take c6 and he he thought for a
long time on this move
I think Queen c7 would have been the
best choice
he played Knight f6 so probably winning
here in several lines
I chose pawn takes and after a check
queen check King f8 and I'm starting to
look at ways of simplifying and getting
Mike Bishop in noticing that the Bishop
on c5 for example would be attacking
both the Queen and the king so are there
ways of setting up some tricky position
of that type first of all I decided by
lifting the rook that I can either
double or maybe I can get the Queen to
go to an awkward square and queen c5
couldn't have been his best move the
bishop at g1 is looking at the Queen
through the two rooks so the question is
now which rook to move and where if I
move the rook on e3 my rook at d5 seems
to be hanging question in the audience
let's see so the question is can i play
rook takes d8 and if rook takes then
rook d3 attacking Queen and threatening
rook d8 and I think if we actually put
this computer in the engine if we put
this position in the engine we will see
that it's it's winning regardless but
that seems like one workable line I just
don't see any way that he's he's getting
out of this here what I actually played
was this move which I thought was very
cute I figured the Queen doesn't want to
take the rook at d4 and once again it's
going to have to move my rook is better
on e5 than he was in his original spot
of e1 and I still have the option of
playing rook d8 later
so now after Queen c7 I found a move
again that I thought was pretty cute
rook c5 so in this position if Queen
takes c5 now rook takes rook rook takes
and Queen falls but I decided against
that move and it's difficult for me to
explain how I could have seen that
something accomplished a goal and not
followed through on it
I played rook takes a 4 I guess because
I also knew that the rook can come to a7
and and already things are pretty simple
Bishop check Queen takes and now he
resigns because rook can't well it can
take Queen but I'm up I'm up a rook and
in fact I have after rook takes c6 wrote
a c8 followed by rook a7 I have a pretty
clear win of the G pawn I'm gonna defend
against a back row mate with something
like h3 and then double the rooks on the
seventh-ranked so yeah that was an
exciting game for me in 2012 a right
before I started working at the Chess
Club and Scholastic Center and since
then have been focusing more on
scholastic chess but yeah fun to play
tournament chess from time to time
now the next game I'd like to look at is
a game by one of our members that's
Julian Perl Aiko this game was played
between an expert playing the white
pieces and Julian Pro Lake Oh another
expert playing the black pieces but
where for Julian because he's from st.
Louis and so the game begins
efore c5 Knight f3 d6 so in the last
game we saw d6 Bishop b5 and here ISA
--cz
Knight c3 so white holding back on the
d3 d4 option we're not quite sure how
the structure is going to develop knight
c6 ok now this looks familiar from some
of these games that I mentioned by
Vladimir but Cline who likes to play
really low paths when his opponent plays
a 5 and he likes to play these Bishop b5
sicilians when his opponent plays
Sicilian so here this should be 5 makes
a lot of sense to me one question is
whether black is willing to double the
pawns on c6 or if he's going to first
play a knight to e7 such that he could
replace that night at c6 so first he
plays Knight at G to e7 castles and now
a six so I like the way Julian's playing
so far he didn't want to compromise his
pawn structure and he still has time to
chase the bishop at b5 it doesn't have a
retreat Square on f1 had white played a
little bit faster and played Bishop b5
on move three without that Knight c3 in
her post he might have had time to play
Castle rook e1 and then bring the bishop
all the way back
to f1 but here he has to take night
takes and d3 Bishop e7 Bishop e3 castles
now here's an interesting move we've
come to like a first sort of key
strategic middlegame decision by
bringing the Knight to e2 why it's
obviously thinking in terms of coming to
f4 or going to g3 is there going to be
some kind of attacking possibility on
the Kings side
Julian probably isn't concerned here he
may play some immediate d5 and he can
play b6 and Bishop b7 he might even play
b5 but first julian an attacking player
wants to take control of things in the
center d5e takes d5 he takes d5 so now
white goes ahead and closes up that
center of the board probably a good
choice because black may have been
threatening were you thinking this
julian d4
right so so let's say he placed
something else like rookie one would you
like to play Bishop g4 or d4 yeah yeah I
like d4 and then let's say the bishop
goes to somewhere like f4 now Bishop g4
and how will he continue he doesn't want
to ruin his pawn structure on the Kings
side so he's either gonna play something
like 93 or could he play 95 the bishop
might start to get loose if the e2
knight is pinned or if if it's removed
so I'm not sure yeah Bishop g4
definitely looks like something that he
should recognize the potential of as
well he so he plays d4 stopping the move
d4 himself and now this interesting move
c4 so Julian you've described this game
as a a sort of positional mindset where
usually you play these very attacking
games so here you're thinking expand on
the Queen side good okay right so by
locking these pawns on light squares it
makes that dark squared Bishop of whites
at e3 a little bit less effective and
meanwhile black has two bishops to play
with so there's certainly looking pretty
good now sometimes we'll crown on
releasing the tension I've certainly
heard people like Gregory kadanoff
talking about maintain the tension but
in this position
maybe the pawn coming to c4 also has an
effect on the minor pieces of white and
so that's that's a very interesting
choice white plays c3 and now the bishop
activates on the colored squares
it spawns have taken up the light square
so Bishop f5 with some possible later
threat of Bishop deep three that c4 pawn
isn't going anywhere anytime soon Knight
g3 Bishop g6 you I guess you could have
played Bishop d3 straightaway okay yes
certainly okay so this kind of gives Y a
chance balls in his court what's his
next idea and that's an interesting way
to play and I also associate it with
kind of a positional technique that we
we put the ball in the court of the
other player and allow them to make some
key strategic decision as long as we're
able to play flexibly we may be able to
take advantage of what decisions they
make
so here rook e1 right we didn't bother
provoking it in the first place
Queen c7 Queen d2 okay so why it's
beginning to pile up with ideas of
moving in on the Kings side could Knight
e5 be in the cards could Bishop f4 come
first followed by 95 those are the types
of things that that crossed my mind
probably what Queen d2 indicates is that
Bishop f4 is coming next but black can
answer Bishop d6 yeah it doesn't look
like too much of a problem here comes
Bishop d6 Knight h4 okay so why it's
willing to invest an extra move to try
to trade off that Bishop pair and now
black has to decide do I want to concede
my bishop pair or can I put my bishop on
the square that looks so appetizing
there d3 so Julian chose Bishop d3
and now some knight or other is eyeing
f5 it must be the h4 Knight
we didn't want to give up the pawn at h2
so yes it's possible to trade that night
but more likely and I think Julian chose
here to play Bishop takes g3 and now why
can either compromised his pawn
structure where he can retreat his only
good minor piece and that's what he does
oh he couldn't have compromised the pawn
structure because he would have lost his
knight okay so now b5 logical move and
it looks like a five and B four could be
coming and I think this is one of the
reasons Julian they you enjoyed this
game so much right you've got that space
and there's really not much that he can
do to stop you is he gonna have to play
some ridiculous looking move like a
three and make a big hole that your
knight can come in a 5 to b3 or or what
he really was missing his LightSquared
bishop here I think and also doesn't did
have to cross his mind to play some move
like b3
shouldn't he maybe even played it as
soon as you played c4 yeah so Knight e 2
is a little bit late in coming in and
trying to to mix things up here I guess
he's considering Knight f4 or night c1
with the idea of kicking that bishop
from d3 interesting strategic choice so
what what good was your Bishop is an
attacking piece his pawns are on dark
squares right what else were you
thinking
yeah there was no good way to stop night
f4 and clearly that was what he was up
to his night turns out to be a more
maneuverable piece in this in this
position or at least based on where it
was at g3 there it had some some latent
attacking possibilities it wanted to
come into f5 or h5 it wanted to go
eventually perhaps to f4 and kick the
bishop now that we've exchanged one pair
of knights getting that night off the
board makes this an interesting Bishop
versus night and game and certainly
because of the structure of the pawns on
the Queen side I'd favor the night there
I think ripped ace so now probably
unless we want to put a rook on the
e-file we can put a rug on the B file
and play a4 a5 and b4 okay a5 rook at a
2 e1 rook at F to e8 so when the bishop
moves no fear because all of the rooks
can come off the board with some move
like Queen d7 I like trading especially
when I've got this much space well I
should I should concede to then I'm not
substituting this class for Yasser
because I have any kind of analytical
ability that their rivals Yasser instead
I'm subbing this class simply because I
was available I think the fact that that
I want to trade pieces in a position if
I were playing the black pieces here for
example where I have an advantage it's
probably bad in my lessons with with Ben
Feingold he always tells me not to trade
when I have the advantage so maybe maybe
some of the title players would be
suggesting here keeping all those rooks
on the board but let's see what happens
next Bishop f4 we're not going to have a
choice so we have to play something like
Queen d7 and now it was White's option
to take the rooks off and he chooses to
play Bishop g3 so
maybe he understands strategy better
than I do I think if I was the white
player even here rather than mission g3
I would go ahead and play rook takes
rook and after rook takes then rotate
see eight Queen takes EI and and I'd be
willing to play that endgame
yes blacks going to get some pressure on
the e-file he may be able to play a move
like Queen B for later on and have some
LightSquared entry points either at d3
or at b1 so those are things to worry
about
Bishop g3 instead so now it's Julian's
choice if he really wants those rooks
off he can make it happen
f6 Queen f4 okay so I guess perhaps
white is thinking that by getting his
Queen to c7 or if the black Queen comes
off of the seventh rank he'll be able to
put some pressure down there not clear
to me that Queen f4 really changes
things much rook takes rook takes e2
rook e8 white doesn't have a lot of
options here he can play rook e3 you can
play rook takes eight but things are
definitely going to clarify quickly King
f1 rook takes e2 King takes e2 so now we
want to ask ourselves whether White has
any way to get in on the Queen side as
long as the queen is at d7 and the night
is at c6
he doesn't appear to he probably doesn't
want to trade Queens because surely the
night is going to be more effective in
this end game than the bishop and in
addition I think Julian probably wants
to keep his Queen on the board Queen and
Knight is a very powerful combination of
pieces Queen e6
Queen e3
king f7 so again white quit take but it
seems like that's not the best option
king d2 and now maybe move like Queen f5
and there's that access on the light
squares that we were talking about there
it is yeah this just doesn't look now
he's done
I think strategically there's no way so
he plays King c1 because he needs to
stop the entry on b1 and it was the only
way to do it and now I think we just
push on the Queen side b4 okay is there
anything white can do does it move like
Bishop d6 help at all your knight is
probably not going anywhere
Queen f4 okay so he repeats but Queen d3
looks like a possibility and Queen f1
and yeah so so just a quick calculation
here Queen c7 Knight a seven Bishop d6
lots of checks and pawn captures and
white is toast is that pretty much
accurate yeah certainly when we talk in
in our scholastic classes about how kids
should think at the chessboard want to
threaten things like checkmate
check threaten major pieces like Queen's
in this position pawn to b3 is a great
move it threatens two significant things
one of which is checkmate and the other
of which is to Queen a pawn on the a
file if you haven't captured
so if b3 comes even if white plays a
takes b3 there's another pawn to replace
it C takes B 3 and now checkmates being
threatened at c2 it looks like
lights-out Queen c7 this is maybe whites
only try 97 pawn takes it looks kind of
like suicide
but maybe there was nothing better after
pawn takes Bishop d6 we have check and
we're gonna gather a lot of pawns
quickly
king d2 Queen takes pawn check King d1
Queen f1 check cute oh you do take here
oh okay
I've got I've got Queen takes d3 in the
computer okay so you take here first and
if he goes back now you can go to d3
yeah sure awesome and he has even fewer
pawns on the board check and yeah just
totally lost that controversial move c5
to c4 is is one of the key decisions
that starts this but also I think white
early giving up that LightSquared Bishop
you know the chess board has light
squares and dark squares and you have to
have pieces on the board who can impact
both of them if you don't you've really
given up fighting for those squares so
yeah that happened to white and yeah
good job taking advantage okay
so this game against Phil parapets key
not to say that black played to the best
of his ability here but this was another
game I was pretty proud of and after
having looked at Julian's positional
ideas I think this one would also be fun
to look at my opponent plays d6 and I
have a fair amount of experience
analyzing some of these lines with with
national master Charles Laughton he
likes to play very aggressively would
probably recommend Knight c3 followed by
perhaps Bishop g5 Queen e2 Castle
queenside and having looked at some of
those and recognizing that black does
have plenty of counter play I just opted
for this more logical completing the
development of my minor pieces so Knight
f3 Bishop g7 Bishop c4 I had played this
move against Josh Frank is about 20
21:50 local player and had gotten a good
game had an advantage if Peter to a draw
but having recently played that game and
having had some success with Bishop c4 I
was pretty comfortable going into this
again castle and now I'm not really
going to think too long
I like Kings safety I like finishing the
the development so I'm my two thoughts
are Bishop g5 and 0-0 in which order not
terribly important first first I played
Queen e2 because I'm still sort of
holding out hope that I can play one of
these lines that Charles Lawton has
suggested to me if I'm putting my bishop
on g5 there is a possibility I'm gonna
want to castle on the Queen side and
even if I don't castle on the Queen side
I can still quickly bring a rook to d1
if I've developed the dark-squared
bishop
so Queen e2 was my attempt at a trick he
played nine c6 and I dropped in Bishop
g5 one question is can i right away play
e5 on the next move how is he gonna stop
that probably has to play h6 or in this
case he plays Knight to d7 now I don't
recommend moving pieces twice in the
opening and my opponents about to embark
on a kind of an extensive Knight
maneuver that I think gives me a lead in
development i play rook d1 which I
wanted to play anyway now I'm certain
I'm castling on the King side and if
Knight b6 I'm just gonna play Bishop b3
and all my pieces are out and I just
don't think black is playing very well I
was surprised that and no knock against
Phil I don't know him very well but you
know usually 2200 develop their pieces
Bishop to b3 Knight a5 so now we've
moved the knight to f6 d7 B 6 and the
other Knight to c6 a5 that's in
investing a lot in Knights I hope bishop
pair is worth that kind of lead in
development
judging from let's see I looked at the
the recent let's see there was a game
where Luke McShane played Carlson and
McShane had white and played to give up
the bishop pair for quick lead in
development that was played in the
London classic in 2010 and you know I
think similarly it's like it's fine to
give up your Bishop if all of your
pieces are out and you're ready to
attack and certainly that's the case for
me meanwhile Black's gonna have to
figure out what to do with the
LightSquared Bishop and neither of his
rooks is actually in the game yet either
so I Castle h6 Bishop f4 c6 I can't
imagine a worse move now the knight
can't retreat from a 5 so it's kind of
stuck out of the game h3 now I started
thinking prophylactic glass and my
developments finished right and my
opponent he's not he's not in Zhuge
swang but he's certainly not in a
position to help himself
anytime it's his move he can only make
his position worse or at least that's
the mentality that I had so here
probably looking for a move he played g5
and now I'm getting pretty excited
because if my development is finished
and his King side is opening up even
more this should be a way for me to take
advantage in exciting style so I played
Ben Feingold's favorite move Bishop c1
now that my rook is in from a1 I'd like
the bishop as far away from the action
as possible Knight takes b3 a takes b3 I
figured that would happen at some point
and now the very curious Queen d7 so we
just looked at a game where positionally
black was playing very well and here we
have a game where positionally I think
black is playing very surprisingly he's
not enterprising and getting his pieces
out he's actually putting them
in a kind of a congested position he
doesn't have any space meanwhile if we
look at the white position and we know
all the pieces are in play the question
becomes how can we activate even more
the first thought that came to my mind
was I want to play pawn to f4 and I
can't do that unless I get my knight out
of the way there's no reasonable place
to put the night other than h2 so that's
what I played now he may play f5 I think
that was one of his best options but he
played this Queen e6 and now I guess the
idea behind Queen d7 comes comes in here
he might be wanting to put that Queen
over at g6 to help defend his King side
looks a little bit late f4 takes and I
played rook takes it's hard for me to
explain why I did this I think it was
because I wanted to play rook h4 and I
also was looking at my knight now at h2
no longer really committed to the f3
square I might be sneaking the knight in
to g4 and how many attackers can I get
on the h6 pawn I think more than he can
get defenders so he plays queen g6 and I
play Knight g4 better was the immediate
rook h4 where even if he plays something
like f5 takes takes now I can play
Knight g4 and for some reason as I had
to calculate these variations even
though I lifted the rook with the idea
of taking it to h4 I think I just got
confused about move order and didn't
realize how potent it was to play row
gauge for straight away and instead put
the knight in first and now I'm gonna
have to move the night before I can put
the rook at h4 well fortunately he helps
me out pawn to h5 now I have to move the
knight so I do and now II five and now I
have to move the rook
so I'm actually getting an opportunity
to fix the mistake that I had made with
my plan Julian
let's see can't the question is can he
play Bishop takes d4 with the idea that
if I play rook takes he plays d5 forking
the rooks and it looks like he may be
able to do that how would I have
answered this do I have anything
reasonable to do
I guess one with I don't know why this
is the first thing that comes to mind
but if I play some something odd-looking
like rook f5 with the idea that if he
takes my rook I play rook g5 that's
pretty wild but his Kings very open so
let's just look at it really quick if he
takes d4 rook g5 Queen takes g5 Bishop
takes pawn takes Knight Queen takes here
I'm pretty sure he's getting mated yes
is there a better line
you can straightaway take the knight on
c3 agreed what if I play Queen takes h5
yeah I like pinning pieces and then and
then like taking advantage of the fact
that they can't move but but yeah I
don't know if this is a good idea I mean
so he can play Bishop takes f5 I can
play
he takes f5 and if he if he takes the
pawn now I can slide the other rook over
to h4 yeah okay I think at this point
Phil is probably in trouble so so yeah I
mean he definitely was looking for ways
to activate the bishop and he played
that a5 move and I captured and he
captured with Bishop I wasn't really
worried about that but I did immediately
start thinking how can I remove the
bishop for me five
so okay first let's put the Rokon h4 and
after a move like f5 my best idea was
probably to play Knight d3 and take his
dark-squared defender the bishop on e5
now my bishop springs into action at
some point it's going to be able to go
to h6 or I can just play rook takes h5
rook h6 followed by Queen h5 so the king
is is pretty open so this is the
opposite of a positional masterpiece I
would say this is a tactical melee but
it's also one that really is in favor of
white on Bishop f4 now this idea you
know not the best way to get rid of the
bishop right I wanted to keep my
dark-squared attacking piece so a lot of
times when we're analyzing our own games
I think it's very useful to look at the
mistakes that we make and and how we
think and I'd like next time next time I
play I'd like to be more cognizant of
which pieces I need to keep on the board
sometimes those are the decisions that
determine whether you win lose or draw
it's just understanding which pieces are
good and if the ones you know that are
bad aren't good how to improve them so
in this case the bishop on c1 was fine
his bishop I I think I was I was looking
at a ghost threat the reason I played
Bishop f4 anybody recognize from what
you know what his bishop a t5 might be
looking at maybe I was I was thinking
well gosh she wants to play Queen g3 and
Queen h2 but gosh that Queen can't go
anywhere because I have a knight
defending h1 but I think just probably
not wanting to calculate a lot of lines
that was what went through my head
anyway the computer preferred 93
certainly I was just talking about
wanting to take advantage of pinned
pieces pieces that can't move and if I
if I allow the Queen to come into g3 I
think one of the things I was worried
about was well gosh then I can't move my
f2 Knight
because the Queen really is threatening
some things down there and also I it
wasn't clear to me that the bishop
wasn't going to be able to go to g3 and
maybe my rook is trapped but that
probably shouldn't have bothered me too
much 93 would have been good where we
could have continued Bishop e6 Knight
takes pawn takes and rook d6 and
although I was looking at ways of
getting my rook into d6
I missed that the knight was going to
take the bishop off the board sometimes
those kinds of things happen in in
calculation so in any event I played
Bishop f4 he played Knight d7 takes
takes and Queen takes h5 so at this
point it's okay for the Queen's to come
off the board they do
and here comes rook d6 and I've just got
a couple minutes left so we can probably
wrap this up fairly quickly the bishop
on e6 is on pre it either has to move or
we slide in the a rook to defend it but
I've got two Knights who are ready to
occupy efore after this rook at 88 move
I I was thinking about exchanging he
takes f5 Bishop takes f5 one of my
Knights to e4 but I decided that if the
bishop was gonna stay at e six maybe
it's better not to take the pawn and to
bring a knight to attack the bishop a
second time so he played Knight g6 which
does stop Knight f4 doesn't stop Knight
d4 and 94 is what I played Bishop f7 and
at this point he actually resigned he
played this movement and realized that
things aren't getting any better
I think possibilities included rook to
g5 followed by pawn takes pawn or even
an immediate pawn takes pawn
the black king at g8 is really pretty
pretty toast so anyway that was one of
one of my favorite games at the time I
suppose since then I haven't had a
chance to play enough rated games but
hopefully I can give you guys some more
at some point in the future
you